Wendy Williams and her on-air scare plus
your roundup of the best celeb Halloween
costumes so far
[Music]
happy Halloween flop my ghouls and
goblins up there
this is the daily dandy and if you can't
tell I am channeling the spirit of
Michael today for today's show and I'm
already sweating but don't worry I am
hydrated which seem to be the problem
for Wendy Williams who got a real scare
on her show this morning
fainting onset culprit the costume get
started our first caress Oh Wendy
stumbles backward and passes out and the
show immediately went to commercial for
six minutes when they came back wendy
was alert and blamed her Statue of
Liberty costume for making her feel a
little green that was not a stunt
I'm overheated in my costume and I did
pass out but you know what I'm a champ
and I'm
[Applause]
the talk show host tweeted after the
incident saying everybody relax I'm
doing fine just need some water and
electrolytes and apparently she's
addressing all of this tomorrow but how
scary was that honest reaction I was
crazy all right
meanwhile can we talk about cardi B's
Halloween costume from the signature red
gloves and black and white hair to this
adorable and real Dalmatian cardi
completely transformed into Cruella de
Vil I love it but does it remind you
guys of another female rapper who once
dressed as the Disney villain this is
Iggy Azalea as Coelho
with the real Dalmatian too in 2013 my
how times change cardi B is going for
your career and your Halloween costumes
Iggy you in danger girl but how's this
for terrifying can you tell which NBA
star went as penny wise from it this
year that my friends is LeBron friggin
James and we cannot stop screaming but
it was way more chill over at live with
Kelly and Ryan both Ripa and Seacrest
actually rocked a bunch of looks
throughout the episode like Wonder Woman
their childhood costumes and even the
Guardians but they opened the show
dressed as each other that's right et
was there behind the scenes where we
asked Ryan what was the best thing about
being Kelly Ripa posture I mean I
actually had decent posture I think
being Kelly Ripa for somebody I could
figure out to sit in that chair
meanwhile the folks over at the Today
Show also got in on the Halloween fun
dressing up as country music royalty
Matt Lauer and Savannah Guthrie are
Dolly Parton and Kenny Rogers and that
is Kathie Lee Gifford as Miley I
freaking love Halloween but before we go
the cast of Sabrina the Teenage Witch
reunited at Stan Lee's La comic-con more
than 20 years since the show first
premiered back in 1996 and only our
Bryce sander was backstage with the gang
after their onstage reunion getting back
together today does it make you think
like hey we should get the gang back
together into a real revival not the CW
on our own well we can't the
unfortunately because of the right
that's where the rights belong we'd only
be in our early 700 century's left to
really we wouldn't eat until we were
like 1500 yeah we got their thoughts on
the CW's upcoming a reboot the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina first of all
didn't know that it was happening
because I apparently live under a rock
how do you feel that somebody else is
gonna be stepping into those shoes I
mean and like psycho and like there it's
like dark it'll have ants and we know
nothing about it it sounds like it's
just gonna be more millennial soap opera
dark you know ours was light and fun and
matter I can't wait to see it you beep
that out right our version was something
family-friendly it's magical it's our
female
everybody can watch it and it's smart
and witty and I feel really good about
that I keep saying that I I but I really
mean it makes you continue believing in
magic which I think we all in the world
need some magic right now Thanks I do
too for the record and speaking of magic
I've got a moonwalk my way out of here
because I want Candis hey but before I
go if you haven't already be sure to
ring the bell on this playlist so you
guys can get a notification for a new
daily Denny episode and I promise you
you won't want to miss what we have
planned for you guys tomorrow all right
how about a night be safe
[Music]